sous ces cornes une grande créatures de
la forêt attire tous les regards malcom
de bouquins comme le bouc je suis apple
fait un grand
je pense que les carottes et ratera une
rencontre que ne serait pas prêt
d'oublier le petit conte ans et sa maman
l'a fait très peur à quentin
principale difficulté aujourd'hui pour
les forces obscures lutter contre le
soleil et la chaleur mais c'est des
esses de la forêt a peut être trouvé la
solution ça va j'ai pas trop chaud dans
cette robe un petit peu mais après ça
regorge d'aération donc ça va et pour
les visiteurs c'est passage obligatoire
au stand de boissons
fraîches par un temps pareil c'est idéal
fait un peu chaud mais en même temps on
est au mois de juin c'est la foire aux
sorcières c'est excellent ces excellents
pas ça très très bon moment outre les
nombreux étals dédié à l'artisanat la
nouveauté cette année c'est le nombre
plus important de scène avec de la
musique ou du théâtre
la sarre à contes tout ce que l'histoire
de france les mariés clovis et tous les
femmes qui sont arrivés au trône comme
en mai en façon humoristique une fierté
pour les organisateurs qui voient chaque
année l'événement prendre de
l'importance la première qu'on a fait
c'est une kermesse une petite kermesse
de village
et puis c'est venu naturellement
s'agrandit et maintenant
c'est comme ça
l'occasion de s'amuser pour les
visiteurs il ya trois ans ils étaient
trente mille a profité de cette foire
sorcières